sokratis Cinepolis is performing with
his quartet he plays a traditional Greek
instrument called the lira it's melody
is an unfamiliar sound to Germany is
this instrument is quite typical
instrument of the Aegean Sea you can eat
it's an old instrument I mean in this
shape you can find it even in paintings
or sculptures of 10th century during the
Byzantine era so this it actually was
that let's say the medieval bowed
instrument which looks like it is the
pre ancestor the grandfather of any
other bowed instrument appeared which
appeared later in Europe the event was
part of an ongoing series of music
performance art and discussions hosted
by Germany's federal ministry of finance
with deutsche welle serving as a media
partner the idea is that events like
this one will help bring European
countries closer together german Finance
Minister Wolfgang shidler attends every
event compared to cultural understanding
he says financial politics is easy can
get a simmer in the end it's about more
important and complicated things
learning how to live together or to
organize our lives together first and
foremost that's what culture is about
the concerts in the series Oh cling to
hope ur the sound of Europe are all free
of charge and open to the general public
bahamas guest by the eyes we invite the
sort of guests who probably would not
appear at a financial summit here they
can see that we are not all just a bunch
of pencil pushers and bean counters
we're also interested in cultured the
staff the Ministry of Finance put a lot
of effort into being good hosts and into
supporting Europe's cultural traditions
at its own and gonzo hope a design some
of Greece's most popular musicians
performed including the internationally
known singer savina Yamato her
appearance came at a time when many
Greeks have sharply criticized Germany
for its actions during the eurozone
financial crisis and that tension made
itself felt that evening it is not just
a concert because we're in a meeting in
the middle of crisis that concerns many
places in Europe also so you are there
and you sing and it is a strange strange
moment
savina annatto sang songs from Medea
composed by eleni kerry andrew who is
famous for her film scores the composer
was also on hand in berlin my music I've
had many human feelings and like the
Melly sadness sadness and prayer you
understand p.m.
the next installment in the series will
take place in November it will feature
the next country in line for the EU
council presidency Italy